what is the worst thing well the worst
thing about Hillary Clinton is her utter
ruthlessness you asked a question so why
why does she do this what drives her the
will to power it's obvious of course she
wants it she wants to be president a lot
of people look at that as a new there's
an ick factor associated with that right
and this it factor can grow over time
accumulates with emails with with the
Clinton Foundation with people she
associates from set herself with Sid
Blumenthal and all the stuff yeah but
here is again another secret to
understanding this presidential race
which is this is a ruthlessness that
voters admire they want their president
to be competent they want the president
to kick ass yeah they don't really care
about all of this stuff there will be
voters who care yeah but most voters I
think even undecided voters that small
tranche of undecided voters in the end
will look at Hillary Clinton will say
okay the job of a president is to be a
hard-ass at times to kick ass take names
the the ends justify the means because
of course the ends involve the security
of the United States economic policy
stuff we agree with her on and she is
she's gonna do it she does no matter
what even if she has to cut corners
she's gonna do it that is an attractive
probably to voters it's not attractive
quality - gugu types in Washington right
so voters it is what makes her almost a
prohibitive favorite is that her worst
quality I think we're down to her
benefit so what I see is sort of the
biggest problem with all our politicians
is really summed up by what you're
saying about Hillary because that
ruthlessness and passion we need that
the desire to do it even if it's as
crazy as we all think it might be I need
at the same time we also want them to be
totally human and we want her to be a
grandma and decent so we're really
asking everything of them and they can
talk everything forever here's what
voters are gonna ask themselves they're
gonna say you know when I trust Hillary
Clinton with my personal bank account or
bill what I trust her with the nuclear
codes
abso-freakin'-lutely and therein lies
the secret to Hillary Clinton's
popularity and why she's the frontrunner
Hillary Clinton would you trust her with
your bank account or the nuclear codes
let us know in the comments right